guys guys messed up you must be wondering Wow Doki you sound
very dead inside
very very good observation because I am
okay guys okay so you know you know how our goal one of our
goals is to end in a fashion or wait what oh okay all right
we're not starting yet i'm i'm just chilling wait am i gonna
be like in there already and then people are gonna be like
wow she didn't even try i i didn't know the game started you
know what let's just watch the fashion show well while i
talk about okay total new lobby what the fuck thank you for
one billion there's enough children for one billion visits
decorated free section oh oh that's me that's me all right
anyway The game's graphics have been changed.
If your graphics are in a high level and experience, okay, I
am not a child, okay, I have, I am an adult with my own
credit card.
I'm ready to be, why would this lag?
It's literally a fashion show.
Why would this be laggy?
It's literally Bratz dolls with fucking clothes.
if i'm actually in here um but like anyway so holy shit look
at her go okay maybe i'll be way too distracted if i okay
guys i'm gonna i'm gonna close this i'm definitely gonna be
way too distracted
okay all right let's let's i'm gonna i have to close it
because i'm gonna be too i can't finish my story if i ever
look at the fashion
okay um um as i was saying so okay so one of my goals is
that i want to end i want to end top 500 in overwatch i'm
back it's back it's back you know like whenever you're in
the very whenever you're you're like i'll never come back
and then the game was like no you'll always come back doki
you know i'm the only one that loves you doki you know you
could never leave so it's like a very you know a very
abusive relationship with this game and i'll be like no i
will never no i won't i got help this time i'll never come
back to you and then later on you're just like oh but like
he's changed guys it's like fun now i swear i swear dragoons
it's actually fun now guys and then everybody else around me
is like no dokey please please you have to finally leave is
he no but you don't understand dragoons i can i can fix it
guys no it wasn't he he wasn't the issue i was the issue oh
anyway anyway um so I I'm back on it I'm back on it and and
um and uh basically I played Overwatch for um for a long
time after after because like today yesterday I had to you
don't know know him like i do we had so many good memories
we got to have 500 together dragons you don't understand i
know i know like i left overwatch several times but like but
like this time for real they're bringing 6v6 back chat
they're bringing they're bringing they're bringing 6v6 back
guys he's going back to his roots i have to be there for
overwatch You know, okay, anyway, um, it's different this
time.
They're bringing...
Oh, 66!
They're bringing back Overwatch 1!
You don't understand!
Bro, Overwatch 1, we're fucking...
The tanks that they have now?
Oh, my God.
I'm, like, thinking Zarya Amaga is gonna be fucking insane.
Zarya with any of the tanks that we have currently and we're
doing 6v6.
Oh, no, we're gonna bring back goats No, we're gonna bring
back goats
No Never mind Sorry, that's that the pain was so real in
that I I just I forgot about goats I remember like what the
fuck is she talking about a goat the gnome it's like a
specific okay for those who don't play overwatch it is
actually like it's a very specific comp um where it's uh
three tanks and three supports and like they don't die
nobody dies Goats was fucking terrible because it's
literally every fucking game in high elo Because if you're
fucking desperate enough you'd be like, please guys, this is
my top 500 game Please can we go goats?
Can we please go goats?
And the reason why people really really fucking hated that
that like particular meta that comp with three tanks three
supports is that Is that basically It's an alt battle It's
whoever fucks up the alt first Because everybody just farms
alt And then it's whoever fucks up Whoever fucks up their
ultimate Loses the team fight And it's so fucking
frustrating At least we have roll Q So there's no way
There's no way There's no way God's going to be back We'll
just have two Really fucking stupid overpowered tanks this
time.
We'll just have incredibly overpowered tanks And it's just
going to be two of them
No, if they can't physically bring back gold because it's
just it's too too too DPS is just going to be a worthless
role But when have they been worth anything in the last two
years?
like all the dps players left to play other games where they
can actually shoot their gun so it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter oh my god anyway so i have a problem right now that's
been happening for like a while for like a um i have a
problem and that's why i'm dead inside at the moment because
I did not sleep much today because I was like after the
after the panel in Singapore I fucking I I went and play
Overwatch but yes I took you today I took you last night
Guys, for those who don't know what it means to tilt Q and
Overwatch, I had my longest lost streak since for I had the
longest lost streak that I ever had in a very long time.
And then, you know, you're like, I can't stop until I break
the lost streak.
can't stop until i break the law street guys or so i was
masters two and then and then i took you to masters four and
i'm at the and i am at the bottom run of masters four like i
am literally one game away from losing Masters 4.
For those who don't understand how bad it is to lose that
much.
Masters 2 Masters 1 is top 500.
And not just top 500.
It's rank 300 to 500.
That's Masters 1.
was masters 2 I was so close I was so um but yeah that's why
uh now I'm that guy that went from no it's masters 4 I
didn't get down there yet I didn't get down there yet I'll
get back I can Get it back, guys.
Today I'll get my master's two back.
I might have meet and greets in a battle at ACG-HK at Hong
Kong, but I'll get it back.
Oh my god.
Stop.
Get some help.
Why do you think I'm playing Dress to Impress?
Why do you...
Let's go gambling.
Ken say thank you for the super chat thank you thank you if
you have a loved one suffering from Overwatch relax please
call this toll-free number thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you seeing on the evil cast will sick of you watch
again next year thank you thank you the super chat thank you
thank you I really appreciate it I'm glad you guys enjoyed
evil that was fun doing the casting all right dressed to
impress Yahoo!
All I'm gonna be is so fashionable!
Alright.
Aquatic.
Oh, okay.
For those who don't know, apparently this is a new hit game
right now and I have no idea why.
Oh, you know what?
I want to know what...
I want to know.
Do I need all of this?
Do I need...
custom makeup why would i need to run fat holy shit the
amount of names they have fucking god oh that's so cute this
game is apparently incredibly popular right now in the
streaming community like apparently even kaiso is playing it
and for those who are like who the fuck is kaiso kaiso is
this generation's tyler one so that would give us the little
context so it's it yeah it's oh and like so it's like oh
that guy that one um literally who yeah like that that's
when you know you're not from this generation right now it's
um basically every generation um every generation has a um
has their own Tyler one.
This is, this is Gen Z's a Tyler one.
Uh, who's Tyler one?
Okay.
This is for, for those who don't know who Tyler one is,
Tyler one is the old generations, um, is the old, old
generation, uh, hot case.
He's, he's, he's, he's, he's, he's like, uh, our
generations, Keso, for those who don't know who the Tyler
one is.
I guess I was like, he's still relevant.
I swear.
Oh my god, I'm naked.
Oh, I don't, oh my god.
Oh no.
I turned down the overall volume of sound.
God.
Oh, you want me to bring?
down i don't even know if that's possible oh there it is
okay maybe if i okay let's see all right there you go i
brought that in the music a little bit too all right okay
case okay basically every generation means oh my god look at
my strut oh it's intermission hey guys i'm the new girl in
town i'm gonna oh my god slay
okay so i could go for some cheese yeah but thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you okay so for those who
don't know who either of those those people are oh my god i
need to grab money because i'm poor this is so fucked up
queen of hearts i don't know all right let's see Yes,
alright, and then Um, no, it have to be Red, no, oh, oh,
Wait, this works, this works, Guys, this works, um And then
we gotta grab some money Cause we're fucking broke as hell
Uh, alright, so every generation We need a We need a
streamer That likes to, okay, we gotta do hair, sorry, give
me a sec I, oh, this one, okay That has to be That's Do we
need beings?
That's that's Queen of Hearts material.
And then on.
No, I can't.
I can't do like two double double colors.
God damn it.
I can't do double colors.
I have to get rid of it.
All right.
How do I how do I get out of the chair?
I finished it.
How do I get out of the chair?
Okay.
I'm don't do well under time limit, guys.
I don't know if you notice, but I I don't I don't do well
when I'm No, I'm not...
I'm not in a prank.
Oh, no.
No, I got the hair, though.
I got the hair.
There's so...
Oh, how did she get that?
Wait, I'm going to copy your clothes.
Wait, $1,000?
I'm not that rich in Roblox money.
I'm going to put a cell phone, though.
Because Queen of Hearts is a fucking boss, bitch.
ready to oh this doesn't need okay this is bullshit that
this doesn't need uh this doesn't need money wait what do i
wear what can i afford what can i oh okay maybe i can afford
this okay uh patterns do i have any heart patterns i oh my
gosh okay i have three minutes uh the most ugly in this boy
what a statement of society right this is a fucking
statement no i need a shirt guys oh my okay i said three
minutes guys i said three minutes i think i look pretty
fucking good not gonna lie i think i look really good all
right no not the men clothing clothing it says queen of
hearts Fuck out.
I need a shirt.
We live in a society.
No, what is this?
No, I'm excluded.
This is the port.
The port.
Come on, we're in the port section.
They're going to, they're going to have no society wins.
No, they'll recognize it.
They've been playing just in frizz for 20 years.
They know what the port section looks like.
back I I have a blue screen it's Roblox I don't fuck I don't
fuck if I'm alright guys I'm gonna I'm gonna get rid of this
Intel card I think it's Intel it's it's always I think it's
Intel card I think Oh my god I actually got kicked out of I
was so I was I was panicking I was I was panicking About the
queen of hearts And then And then I And then they kicked me
out They kicked me I couldn't even
sit Okay I think I know why guys I think I might know why It
could be Okay I think I fucked up by down i underclocking my
pc for marvel rivals so because like i think that's what did
it i think that's what happened i don't know i wonder if i
could like fix it like manually but basically um i
underclocked uh i underclocked my pc because it was
recommended by the game um to to underclock
specific to like 53x and yeah i undervolt yeah i undervolted
because like marvel rivals would not boot up and then marvel
rivals has like a recommendation um that was like we can't
run this game on intel 13 so you have to under undervolt it
sorry i meant yeah i undervolted guys but then i re-volted
it after the stream so like i i undid the undervolt and uh I
hate it was recommended by the game so I did that and I
think after that that's when the blue screen happened so um
do I just yet yeah so like I think that's what happened
because the game Marvel cannot run um cannot run uh the game
you cannot run the game will crash basically the game will
crash if uh uh i ground my cpu did i actually did that i did
one stream i did one fucking stream Oh my god, I did one
stream and my CPU is already fucked.
Oh my god, but I redid it.
I didn't even play Marvel Rivals for that long.
There's no way.
Do I keep it undervolted?
Do I actually keep it undervolted for until...
I don't know.
Oh my god.
Bro.
It's not.
Yeah.
Basically.
Okay.
I'll keep it.
I'll.
It could help.
I'll keep.
I'll keep it undervolted then.
I had it like.
Because like now I.
After the Marvel rival stream.
I did it back to.
I did it.
back to uh to the original um but then like then i started
then the blue screen started happening for the stream i
think that's what i think that's what happened to pc koon
too that's like i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure that's also
what happened okay i i changed the performance core ratio
i'm gonna go back to 53 then okay i'm gonna try and put an
amd i'm gonna do that on the weekend um because like you
know there's there's so much stuff going on all right i i
undervolted i undervolted it again so um we'll see if this
works i i forced the undervolt all right this is the weekend
i there's a lot going on guys i never thank you for the
thank you oh no i need it i need it this pc is so heavy
oh my god edit amd motherboard oh
all right anyway i guess i'll look into that to tomorrow.
Okay.
I need a... I just got this PC.
Oh my god.
I just... I just bought this PC.
Like, I...
Okay, too fair.
I got this PC for free, but now I'm spending money on this
PC.
Now I'm spending money.
Holy shit.
I'm spending money on this PC.
I just got... I got it.
for free
anyway are you guys sure are you guys sure i should keep it
like undervolt or or because like it's been on i only had it
undervolted for marvel rivals and then i uh i only um uh i
only have it undervolted for marvel rivals and then i did it
back to uh and then i did it back to the vault which was 57x
uh just to be safe yes it could die okay all right all right
um yeah okay i'll do i'll keep it under vaulted all right i
can't believe it there's too much vault charge in roblox
it's fucking roblox it's fucking roblox i all right what's
the new what's the new new Okay, anyway, as I was saying,
Oh, choose the next theme.
Oh, I don't, okay, I want I want FNAF.
Not a theme props?
I don't have, okay, I'm too poor to choose.
Guys, guys, they won't let me pick because I'm too poor.
I don't, I can't pick because I'm too poor.
The theme is Ghost versus ghouls.
Okay, ghost versus ghouls in the poor section.
I wish I had queen of hearts.
I wish...
Wow, she flipping.
Okay, I need the money.
I need...
She already has clothes on.
Ghost versus ghouls.
Ghosts, I'll be a ghost.
Ghosts are easy.
Okay, um...
What is spooky?
What...
Um...
Oh my god.
What is a spooky?
Where's the spook?
Okay, there you go.
Oh, she looks like, you know, a screamer.
She looks like a screaming ghost and then all white.
Okay.
Uh, and then bangs.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I don't like that.
Let's do like full white bangs.
Oh, I don't like that.
I don't like that way I can combine.
Uh, I'll do bangs.
That'll be cute.
Okay, nice.
All right.
So be unique.
Yeah, there you go.
I'm unique.
Okay.
Um, Where?
How do I not be?
How do I not be blue?
Oh, it's makeup.
Oh, I can have I need money for makeup I'm
poor I can't believe it.
I need money for makeup Okay, um Uh All right, that's cute,
right?
That's cute.
Oh God okay um yeah that's fine I'll do that I'll do that
I'll do that okay why am I blue I don't want to be
blue okay oh screen isn't cropped no my screen isn't cropped
correctly I'm sorry I'm a mess right now I'm a fucking mess
I'm a no guys please please give me some time please
children please children children let me have a little bit
of time children please anyone say nobody wants to talk to
the poor nobody wants to talk to the poor um um what what
what is googly oh i can be a old victorian googly no okay no
that's ugly I can be a oh I can have a necklace yes yes yes
oh your outfit is
your outfit so good your cup does what I was I'm gonna copy
your shit fuck you bitch I I'm gonna steal your fit I'm
gonna do it I ain't no fucking I'm not scared I'm gonna
steal your fucking fit all right um have some empathy
children oh wait what's this wait oh fuck I don't want this
how do i take it off how do i take it off how do i how do i
take it off oh okay um okay i don't i um yes i'm gonna no
okay we're gonna make do of this we're gonna we're gonna
make do with this it's not what i want to take off but when
you have a minute left i'm not okay i'm not okay right now
i'm not i mean i'm not okay at the moment um um i want uh
okay there we go there you go That's ghoul-y.
Oh, okay.
No, not like that.
Uh, how do I get the other color?
I want to change that color.
Oh, over here.
Okay.
Uh, there we go.
Does this feel ghoul?
Oh, this is terrible.
This is so bad.
Everybody else looks so good.
That is not ghost versus ghouls.
Get the fuck out of here.
Let's hack some squidweed.
How do they change?
How do they...
Oh, it's a ghoul.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Okay, guys, guys, we're still, how do I change my color?
How do I, no, I'm too poor for that section.
No, stop telling me how poor I am.
That's a zombie.
That's a zombie that looks like Squidward.
Oh, nice, I got $18.
How do I, how do I, is it here?
Oh, it's my nails.
Okay, um, there we go.
Nice, lay girl.
See, if you have no money, it's, it's okay.
The pods.
the pods there's pods for the pop people that the the white
lights near the jeans the fact that you guys know so much
about this scares me a little because it tells me that you
guys definitely spent money on this game like shoes shoes
i'm looking at no shoes oh no oh no where are the shoes at
where are the shoes at okay i'm gonna put these on i don't
have anything else guys i don't i'm
I'm...
My internet is seed.
No!
My internet...
I...
I fucking
put me on the show of my fit!
I'm not...
What is wrong with me today?
I'll never be able to be fashionable.
I just wanna, I just wanna be fashionable with the children.
Wait.
I can't, I can't, why is Roblox?
Why are you like this?
Roblox, no, I can't even, I don't know why hero blocks why
is everything not working um everything is not okay nothing
is okay right now oh it's the arcade okay we're doing this
again oh my god I feel so far right now I feel like I'm I
feel like I am role playing as My internet I forgot to pay
my internet bills I have to be poor I'm done at the VIP
beach Everything is full Today's not the day I never get to
show my fit At all It's so Fuck I'm fucking gonna be Freddy
Fazbear I'm gonna be Freddy Fazbear This is gonna be Horror
horror horror Hoor, hoor, hoor, I don't know.
Hoor, hoor, hoor.
Hoor, hoor.
Oh my god.
Oh, shit.
I'm gonna be, I'm gonna be a fucking star.
No money, no internet.
Children bullying me.
I, I just, I just, I just want it.
I just want it to be Freddy Fazbear.
All right.
Give me it.
I don't know.
What is Freddy?
All right.
There you go.
They won't know.
They're going to be like, what the fuck is wrong?
This bitch is fucking fit.
Like, I'm sorry.
I'm trying my best.
I am.
I really am.
Try.
I don't know what else would Freddy Fazbear, what would
Freddy Fazbear look like if he was, if he had, if he was a
bear.
Oh, this, this, this, this, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay.
Wait, this is what he'll look like if he was a bear.
Wait, I mean, if, sorry, this is what he would look like if
he was a person.
He's already a bear.
Sorry, he's already...
Guys, I'm not okay right now.
I DC'd twice.
I DC'd and then I fucking blue screened like and pick a
struggle.
Doki, pick a fucking struggle and lane and I'm getting
bullied by children who have spent their mom's credit card
money to...
Okay.
No, I don't have $5,000.
I don't even know how much money I do have.
Like,
holy shit.
I'm trying to be Freddy Fazbear from the arcades.
That's themed, that's a theme right now, okay?
I'm trying, do I, oh my God, he picked Penelope!
Okay, I'm trying to know what pants to wear.
Oh my God, okay, that's a fucking dolphin.
That's nice.
Alright.
There we go.
Freddy Fazbear.
Okay.
I need to change my...
I need...
I need to get pants.
Like, I don't know.
Oh.
Okay.
There we go.
And then...
Let me change my clothes.
Okay.
Oh.
What the...
What tone is that?
There you go.
That's a fucking dolphin.
Like, what?
That's not even.
Oh, no.
17 seconds.
Any pants?
Um, what goes well?
Ah!
Oh, this doesn't look good.
Oh, I put everything on.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Do you think they'll recognize it?
Do you guys think the children will recognize it?
Recognize it.
Okay, you're not even trying.
You're not even one star.
That's not even... You're not even trying your best right
now.
Like, what is this?
What is this?
You just put everything on!
Oh, wait.
They put...
What the fuck?
Bro, Brian's a runaway queen!
Three stars.
Oh my god, Brian is a...
Oh my god, and he's doing the Mario poses!
Oh, these kids!
Who the fuck is Lucille?
What are you?
One star.
Like, what are you?
You're just going to the goddamn mall!
Like, this is not a fit...
That's just a girl.
That's just...
Like, at least...
Bro, that's two girls!
You do not see these girls in a fucking arcade.
Like, that is not arcade material.
How are you gonna play?
How are you gonna play the drum game in that fit?
Girl.
Your makeup's gonna run with full of sweat because you're
trying too hard.
So true.
But she has...
She plays...
You can't even play!
What's this?
That's not arcade.
You don't even, you can't even, you're a fashion maven.
Go back to fashion school.
What is that?
What the fuck?
What are you getting?
Try to get some bitches?
Like, wait, oh, you're gonna jump around.
That is not Mario.
The fashion maven.
One star.
This is not to the theme.
Guys, guys, do they think they notice that I'm Freddy
Fazbear?
Do they think they have from the arcade?
Come on.
Yeah.
Ooh, I'm so confident right there.
Horror, horror, horror, horror, horror.
They have Luigi?
Oh, my God.
Three stars.
I'm like the Asia star rating because in Asia apparently
people don't rate people don't rate above three star
Wait, no No, that's a minion.
Wait a minute.
That's a fucking minion.
That's not even arcade That's a good costume, but that's not
to theme not to theme Girl you cannot you cannot do that and
just not be to theme Oh, wait, you can...
Oh my, this is not fair.
She's clearly rich.
This is not fair.
Three stars.
This is cheating.
She clearly has money.
Like, this is so fucked.
You're clearly... I... This is not fair.
They went in with Mario and Luigi.
kids oh i got fourth i got fourth i got fourth yeah fuck you
bitches i might be poor but i have style and fashion i knew
what the kids like and the kids like for now i know i knew
what the children like to see and the children like
Not last.
I got third place for that first time.
Oh my god.
Guys.
This is my first.
The first game.
And I got fourth place.
I just can't.
Oh my god.
Slay.
Anyway.
Let me win then.
Luigi isn't a girl, it's a man What the fuck Wait
Oh shit Bro, okay Wait, how do I get rid of my clothes?
Okay, how do I get rid of my makeup?
What is this?
Um How do I get rid of my makeup?
First lady Oh shit, what the fuck?
okay um white um um i don't know i don't know we don't have
first ladies we have prime ministers and first minister
first lady minister what do we call him we call the prime
minister his wife Like, what do we even call the prime
minister's wife?
I don't fucking know.
What do we call the first prime, prime lady?
Yeah, we just call our wife.
She's just wife.
Like, I'm not American.
What the fuck am I supposed to know what the first lady
looks like?
Okay.
Oh no.
Horror, horror, horror, horror, horror.
Optimus Prime.
She's an expensive gal.
That's when you know this first lady is fucking committing
tax fraud.
Was it called when they dip into the funds?
When they start dipping into government funding?
for it a felony yeah but there's a word for it embezzlement
yeah that's when you know my lady is embezzling that's when
you know they always have the same haircut like the like no
not this one like oh it's sort of like that but short like
not wait less wavy it's short of sort of like that just make
Michelle Obama like I'm already halfway I'm already there
you know I'm already there
I'm already there like okay um fucking we fall um let's see
there you go I think we're there I think I think we did it
be her right i don't know i don't pay attention to what's
going on in america oh i need a bag you're right you're
right i need a bag all right there you go easy is there like
a nicer bag like a nicer like i'm the i'm the first lady bag
you're so fake you're so firstly here right now wait oh yeah
yeah yeah like this right No, she doesn't wear that hat.
I don't fucking know.
I don't remember what she wears like I barely pay attention
to the fashion anyway Thanks to thanks to Obama.
Thank you for the super chat.
That's a dead well, thank you.
Thank you Why is there a mermaid?
I don't fucking know why there's a mermaid here like My god
you guys know more about the first lady than I do stop
there.
I'm not rich somebody guys my stream sniper fucking stream
snipe me on vip right now
give me my
guys guys i'm like i'm the charity case guy i need to stream
snipe me on it as well give me a scholarship right now give
me a scholarship and get me out of here i don't want to be
I'm getting bullied by children
The first lady needs funding she can't keep embezzling Like
I'm like freaking restricted with everything.
I did not there's like four hats here.
There's literally four hats Like bro you copy my fate I'm
Michelle Obama That's not Michelle Obama.
Look at you.
You fucking Michelle Obama never wears red.
I think I don't know.
I don't pay attention She stole my fit.
Fuck you bitch
I'm Michelle I claimed I claimed the obamas first like
There's only room for one Michelle Obama.
I'm picking up for two Michelle's.
There's one...
It's not First Ladies.
It's First Lady.
Like, come on.
Mrs. President.
Mrs. President, get down.
No, no.
She's like conservative.
She's...
Oh, wait, no.
Today, she doesn't want to show her legs.
She doesn't want to show her legs today, guys.
Um, okay.
Okay.
She doesn't want to show her legs today!
She's got to do it for the kids!
Jesus, that's not first lady!
What the fuck are you?
That's a...
That's snow white!
That's a white dog!
Like, that's a first lady princess.
Which finally father was a lady.
One star for not even being on theme.
Blank, what the fuck?
Oh yes!
I got my scholarship!
Peace out, nerds!
I'm going to boarding school.
I'm going to a private boarding school.
I'm going to Ivy League now.
I crawled through from the poor to become to get my
scholarship.
Yeah!
No shot no way one star not even a theme that's who is that
are you Clearly the first woman.
Oh my wait, that's actually so smart wait Eve the first
woman created by God.
Oh Yes Okay, that was good.
I wish I could I wish I could actually change the the vote.
That's actually really good Oh my god Yeah Obama
Michelle Holy shit Michelle I can't believe Obama got
censored I'm like I do things Obama I can't How can I say
Thanks Obama Who's Jackie?
That's a child Oh my god That's a child Somebody literally
said Who's Jackie?
Holy shit Who the fuck is her?
Oh no Yeah I didn't do any poses Because like The first lady
has to be reserved and like who the fuck oh that is what is
that dang you don't plan okay one star everybody gets one
star yeah but she does one hell of a split I like how
everybody's like who are you oh my god one star you fucking
fit stealer Michelle would never win those Where's those
fucking, um, necklaces?
Michelle would never do a dead drop.
I literally searched Michelle in Pinterest.
I apologize.
You cheated!
You Googled in Pinterest?
I did it from memory.
I did that from fucking memory.
And this bitch cheated.
I'm looking up on Pinterest.
It like literally came to me in a dream.
Who are you?
I feel like I'm playing.
I'm sorry, Michelle.
I failed you.
I'm playing in Olive Garden.
The wife.
Suss.
What is this game?
I'm playing in Olive Garden.
Oh, okay.
This one's...
recognize her right here who is jill at least he can blame
on olive garden guys i have to be first place from that i'm
there yes i did it thank you obama thank you wait thanks
obama thank you
Thanks, Michelle.
They can't even say thanks, Obama.
Even if I put in a space.
That's right.
I got my scholarship.
I am poor like you guys now.
I got it from Shira Will and being fabulous.
Thanks.
My god, I have VIP access now.
The Roblox thing.
No, Obama is censored no matter what.
I can't even, like, I can't even, um, I can't even, like,
fucking do it with, like, a space in between, too.
Yeah, that's right.
I'm not a charity case.
I'm just special.
They could see how good I am.
mythology You guys are gonna be on the poor section See you
later losers I'm fabulous and Oh wings oh my god Wings
mythology I'm gonna be I guess I'll be an angel That's not
that I'm not Didn't mean that I didn't oh my god Could be
Mikuatsune Mikuatsune is technically a Mythological creature
Okay I Um, I could be an elf.
Okay, here we go.
Um, I want to do like, I want to do like, uh, uh, what's his
name?
The Hermes.
I want to do Hermes.
Is there like, is there like shoes with wings?
I'm going to be Hermes.
Miku is Legendary.
Okay, let's see.
See you later.
I got the rich people section now.
Let's see.
Is there rich people hair?
Where are you?
Yeah, I need wings on shoes, but like, where am I going to
find that?
What would Hermes look like if Hermes was a woman?
Alright.
Okay.
Woo!
If Hermes was a woman, what would you look like?
To be fair, back then, like, they're turning to women and
men and just...
everything to be fair so like wait this is such a tiny area
for the worst section that's it I'm rich and this is all I
get the poor people get like 200,000 like like outfits
that's not fair it's her me's not in me that's so true so
that's so true so good that's so fucking good what the fuck
I mean it's not fair they're ready sea creatures like what
they're ready sea creatures what am I supposed to do with
that okay alright we're gonna I'm Hermes but my wings are on
my back instead of my shoes that's really good I know I was
like Wait, what's this?
Ooh, no.
Wait, oh, Villaco.
I know what that is.
Okay, let's see.
Is there a shoe I can put it on?
That's like vaguely wing-like.
Oh, okay, we're gonna put on this.
Um.
Oh, I can be a Valkyrie!
I'm just gonna be like, I'm a Valkyrie.
Oh my god, you're right.
You're right.
I'm a Valkyrie.
Wait, oh my god, you guys are so smart.
You guys are so fucking smart.
Okay, um.
That is the shoe base.
I need to change this.
I'll change it to...
Oh my god, you guys are so fucking smart, though.
Let's see.
I'll do...
I think it should be white, actually.
With an iron is a logical...
Holy fucking shit.
that's right i'm a valkyrie okay i'm just gonna be like this
this entire time all right all right let's see a minute and
48 seconds is there a way i need to get a sword i know dude
i don't think they're gonna have swords i don't think
they're gonna have swords in fucking roblox i cannot even
say i can't even say thanks obama you think they're gonna
have swords like you really think Yeah, I'm like, if I can't
even say thanks, Obama, you think they're gonna give swords
in this game.
Alright, let's see, what's this?
Oh, okay.
Maybe.
Oh, my God, okay, I got jewelry on.
I got jewelry on.
I think it's good.
I think that Twilight Sparkle!
Okay, take it to her.
Twilight Sparkle is a mess!
She's real to me.
It's so fucked up.
What the fuck?
Hey, we don't fuck.
You guys are seeing there's like...
There's like a...
Yeah, I'm a Valkyrie.
A Valkyrie doesn't wear...
A Valkyrie doesn't even wear halos.
What do you mean?
let's see is there actually any wings on no okay God I wish
there was a sword I wish there was a sword it's not fair I
want a sword
I think that's the perfect I can do this is the best I can
do guys in the scenario I'll just be like I'm a Valkyrie
Vote for me children What else can I do?
What the fuck is this?
What is that?
I'm a disco ball because I didn't like this
Give you two star for that.
I'll give you
What the fuck is she?
Is that Zeus?
How?
Why does that suit have a microphone?
Why does he have a microphone?
Guys, it's all about the theming.
Guys, oh.
I'm a Valkyrie.
Oh my god.
Breath taken.
Yes!
eight best one yeah oh who's that what the fuck get educated
you little child you baby okay all right that phoenix gets
two stars that phoenix such i can't believe it this bitch
said who's that go back to fucking school before you go to
fashion school get an education i'm getting it
I'm Meg from Hercules movie Why do you have a bait?
Why do you have a basketball?
No, no, no, he's, no, why does she?
Oh!
Slave.
That shit is fire.
Oh my, five stars.
Oh my god.
Girl, you know.
what's up girl oh my god girl you know what's up you know
what's slay girl like that's actually so good i forgot to do
poses oh i can't i forgot to do poses uh two stars 10 10 out
of 10 she's a flop bro girl you ate and left no crumbs Oh my
god, is that, is that like Twilight Sparkle?
Oh my god.
I know I can't be you because I'm me.
Good toky.
Oh my god.
What the fuck is her?
I'm toky.
Bro, what?
Why do I look like trash?
Why?
I'm from Etsy.
No one knows who this is.
Hey, I see.
I think I think Doki Bird is a pretty cool individual.
She's pretty slay.
Doki Bird from Etsy.
Who is Doki Bird Law?
I heard, I heard she's like, she's a fashion vlog.
I heard it.
I see.
Sorry.
Alright, who's next?
Alright.
What the fuck is this girl?
You're, you're, are you trying to say women are a myth?
Like, I ain't trying to say women.
What are you?
You're just women.
Yeah!
Oh, shit.
Like, I robbed.
Okay, to be fair, I definitely robbed Medusa.
I definitely, I definitely robbed her from the wind.
I definitely robbed her from the wind.
The biggest upset of the century.
You did not deserve this.
Oh my god.
I definitely did not deserve this win.
Alright, farmer.
Not a theme props?
What do you mean?
Oh, I need a buy to decide the theme.
The rich really do decide the world.
The rich.
Yet again.
It runs this world.
Oh my god.
Somebody put farmer in there.
Somebody pay to put farmer in the fucking category chat.
What the fuck is this?
This is parkour.
The theme is sci-fi.
What the fuck do I be in sci-fi?
No, I'm not.
I don't feel ready.
Um...
Oh, no.
What do I be in sci-fi?
What would be...
Uh...
Star Trek?
These children don't know what the fuck is Star Trek!
You know what?
Is Miku...
Wait, Miku Hatsune is technically sci-fi.
You'd think... Is Miku sci-fi?
Is she sci-fi?
You know what?
Wait, you're gonna be Miku?
Bitch.
Take that shit off right now.
You're not gonna be Miku.
I'm gonna be Miku.
Girl, I was here first and I'm gonna be Miku.
That's right.
That's turn around, right?
Now, that's fucking right.
Know your place.
Know your goddamn place, child.
No, no.
That's sick.
right that's good that she knew her place that's the actual
fashion drama I am a rising star in the I will be the land
then that's right all right let's see okay there we go we
got the right colors and then oh wait that has to be black
so there we go all right that's right uh and then we're
gonna have to get the hair uh we're gonna grab the hair here
i'm not gonna socialize with the with those beneath me right
now like i'm a star i'm i'm a goddamn fucking star i'm not
gonna socialize with those that beneath my existence.
Wait, where's the Miku hair?
Where's the Miku hair?
Wait.
Where is it?
She literally had Miku hair.
It's from my code?
What's the code, guys?
Guys, what's the code?
I need the code.
I can't live without it.
How do I...
guys what's the code guys we have two we have two there's
what's the code the code is for guys we need the miku hair
it's not boobs i am bella slay okay that's not numbers
that's an invalid code oh is it all is it l Bella's Slay.
Is it L?
Oh, is it I?
I.
Oh, my God!
Slay.
Okay.
Come on.
Miku hair color.
There we go.
I am sci-fi.
Miku is sci-fi.
Okay, we're gonna give Miku some sci- You know, I can pick
whatever the fuck I want.
I own this fashion in this I like I've never changed my
makeup at all.
I haven't changed my makeup at all throughout this life I
just I just kept this on since since the very start.
Okay let's see I could be vampire Miku.
Oh my god I'm gonna be a vampire Miku.
I'm gonna, I'm in, I'm in, I'm muleing right now, I'm, I'm
muleing, no, this is, I'm the muleing Miku, alright, let's
see, and then get the microphone, there we go, Sune Muku,
yes, yes, children, I'm at Sune Muku, Mewku I that's right
chill oh my gosh she's the angel from dr. who I can't
believe you guys were like be Star Trek these children will
never recognize Star Trek like they'll just be like they
literally was like who the fuck is Jackie like they don't
even know who Jackie was they saw Michelle Obama and was
like oh I know her and then everybody else was like who the
fuck What is that?
That's not even sci-fi.
What are you?
God.
Is this why you do not have VIP?
That's right.
Um, it's Hatsune Miu-ku.
Get it right, girl.
Like, oh my god.
Get it right.
Is that shaggy?
Miu-ku?
I'm Hatsune Miku.
It's giving.
Oh, my God.
That face is giving up five stars.
So good.
Thank you, darlings.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, love it.
Slay.
That phone.
No, I forgot to pose.
I keep forgetting to pose.
I got so absorbed.
I don't need to pose.
I own the industry.
Ladies.
Who is that?
Is this a...
Who the fuck is that?
I don't know what this is.
I don't need to pose.
all my sides are my good side wait oh my god how much side
five five stars though five stars guys give j five stars
that is beautiful no way is that is that sci-fi dokey breed
guys you better oh e from wally that was an attempt
I don't know you're just not me you're just it's it's you're
just not me like I don't know
oh wait that's actually pretty good that's you know what
with every Hatsune Muku needs a Len so you get you get a
four star you get a four star she thought she was what the
fuck is that is that actually shaggy chat is this rin
i'm separate timeline instead of vtubing i became a bio
engineer i didn't even vote that's how it was i hate green
shag who's that i'm wally oh you're a Wally!
One star.
I didn't know until you said you're Wally.
So, like, I don't know.
It had to be very...
It has to be, like, very obvious to me that you're Wally.
If you have to tell me you're Wally, then it's not good
enough.
I'm sorry, darling.
It's just not good enough.
It's just...
You just didn't need to try a little bit more.
I am...
Is that Tom Cruise?
Wait, who's this?
That cosplaying as a scientific tomato.
Two-star.
Scientific experiment.
Cute.
If the tomato can't be...
No, a tomato.
If the tomato can't be a fashion model.
What will it look like?
Where are you?
I don't know.
I just did.
Okay, one start.
You didn't even try.
You're a runway queen and you didn't even try?
God, whose daddy helped you get here at the top?
Somebody clearly used daddy's money to get here.
Get out.
What the fuck?
This bit is really good.
That person was AFK.
The winners are.
Yay!
I think I fucked up this lobby.
I'm pretty sure I messed up the lobby, guys.
Take a photo.
Take photos.
Oh, my gosh.
Come on, paparazzi.
Go over here and take some photos of my true rifle place.
here don't worry i might not have posed oh yeah that's right
that's right everybody oh yeah that's right do post 12
what's post 12.
is this this oh is it a jojo pose
all right all right guys wow guys i'm a natural i'm actually
a natural at this now i know why queso is obsessed with this
wait i can join the oh i can join the vip exclusive servers
oh guys i need a real challenge everybody i i need a real
challenge i think as a rising star that i made it in this
world to go the next level all right elements oh god wait
elements okay uh uh go to oh they're fine okay if they're
gonna be fire i'm gonna be water i'm gonna be water i'm i'm
thinking quick right now i'll be water all right guys i'm
sorry but like clearly clearly i deserve to be here um
because i got so many wins guys so i mean all i'm saying is
that i am i think i am ready to be in the big leagues i'm
ready to be in the big leagues now oh yes okay we're gonna
oh yes all right we're gonna be the element of water oh okay
uh let's see what what how what is good What is good?
Or should I have a bodysuit?
Wait, should I have this on?
Ooh, I don't know.
I don't know.
Let me... Doing our Gucci villain arc.
No, I feel like...
Since, like... Wait, how...
How are they, like, mermaids?
You guys saw that, right?
They were, like, mermaids at one point.
Like, how are they mermaids?
Let's see.
Nope.
God, we'll be a good fit.
Ooh.
Yes, yes Oh, oh my god, yes Code?
Guys, we need to be a mermaid Guys, we're literally Code,
give me the code, guys, we gotta win this We gotta beat
these guys We're in the big leagues, girls We're in the big
leagues
Mer-a-maid Alright Oh my god, yes Oh my god, yes my god oh
you're gonna you're gonna beat this competition doki oh my
god like they don't know what's coming hey we gotta grab
this hex code and then change this to this and then change
this to this there you go wait what not the code oh there
you go oh my god you are so you're ready you're so ready
dokey you have to think to an hour ago you were just beneath
them and look at you now girl look at you now
oh my god it is possible anybody can be a star
Anybody can be a star.
If you just try hard enough.
And if you can't, you just weren't trying.
Let's see.
Alright.
You just weren't giving your all.
That's all I'm saying.
You can't make it here.
You weren't trying your best.
What is this?
Oh, yes!
It's like seaweed!
I can make this like seaweed!
Oh my god!
Yes!
Okay.
All right.
Oh my god.
It's like nature.
God, how do you keep doing this?
How are you just so good?
Oh my god, wait, this works.
Wait, this actually works.
How are you just...
Oh my gosh, Doki.
You're literally unnatural at this.
I'm trying to figure out if I want this fit.
Like the dress with the...
Oh, but maybe if I put a belt on it, Like, if I put a belt
on top, and then, uh, oh, no, the belt doesn't, the belt,
oh, I can make it bigger?
Wait, how do I, is that not the belt?
Where is it?
No, I can't, I can't fit the belt.
Oh my god.
Let's see.
That's what you're going in.
It's called elements, girl.
What element are you the element of shit you
might as well leave now don't even bother going to the
judging panel
wow rude okay that's when I know I'm in the big leagues oh
my god you gonna tell the uh don't keep these are children
Age doesn't matter in the world of fashion You either have
it or you don't
One star What element are you?
Trendsetter?
More like Go home What even is this?
The element of lady What element is this?
Oh Oh, that's fire, but I know you're- this is from...
I don't know.
Fire.
More like Go Homer.
What is this?
Is this nature?
Girl, look at color theory.
Go back to school to figure out what color theory is.
Like belongs in the trash.
Oh, and that's how you do Earth, Bella.
Maybe you should go back to the free section to all.
That's how you do Earth, girl.
Yes, a slave!
Fire!
Can we get some snaps?
There it is.
Now, that's an Earth element.
Yeah, that's really good.
What the fuck is this?
Water and fire?
No.
Do not mix.
Water and fire don't go together.
Oh, they're talking about elemental.
But what about elemental, Doki?
That's a children's film.
Water.
That's all I'm gonna write.
No, no, I forgot to pause.
I keep forgetting to pause.
What is, snow is not an element.
You wish it was an element.
Have you never played Pokemon before?
Fire, what, oh wait.
It's ice.
Snow is not ice.
It's just water.
Snow is an element.
That's not even ice.
That's air.
I'm third that bitch is not even air like
how can you tell it's air fucking clouds
the first thing I see is like not god this lobby is so
beneath me they cannot see real talent they
no i'm not prox how many points do i have how many how many
points do i have i no it's not it's truly a streamer how do
i how many points do i have i'm 165 can you gift stars or do
you have to grind that out yeah that's what you deserve i
want to i want to be in the big leagues these don't deserve
me i got third place chat i got third from first favorite
aesthetic what a garbage i'm doing another no this server
what a garbage element that's not even like um that's not
Not even a real theme.
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
This theme fucking sucks.
This is third is not third.
That's a non-theme.
That's literally a cop-out.
I need a real challenge.
It's still favorite aesthetic?
Am I...
There's only one server?
tell me when this aesthetic is over I can't I can't deal
with that I can't deal with people giving like um I it can
be anything scene that's not you either you gotta go hard or
go home you can't just be like um I like any minimalist
versus the maximalist what the fuck is that the just don't
fucking put on anything like what oh wait wait I have an
idea I have an idea okay okay where where is there you go
wait can I change no I can't I don't have any clothes on all
right where's like the where is like the this the I'm
cooking I'm cooking I'm cooking something I need like the
shortest thing they have so I can do something silly.
I need something.
I need like a bikini.
Where's it?
Oh, yes.
Okay, what color is this?
I can color match this, guys.
I can do it.
I can color match this.
Guys, it'll be easy.
Okay, I'll spend the entire time color matching this until I
get it perfect.
I uh What the fuck is that Okay wait It's almost there We're
almost there We're almost there guys
Okay there you go It's the best I can Okay we need like It's
like
Minimalist!
I'm literally...
I'm giving the minimalist look right now!
What do you want from me?
Literally minimalist.
Chat.
I'm doing my best here.
To give you nothing.
Go, go, Doki.
Give us nothing.
If they didn't want me to do all of that, I...
They would have taken...
that theme out like if if they didn't want this this would
not be a theme they they know damn well what's gonna happen
they know damn well what would happen let's see he's like
but you give us that is it's so minimal how it's is not
minimalist how do they have a fucking bra but no no like i
don't know shorts or tights or like uh bikini bottoms all
right let's see i mean this is the closest we have this is
literally there we go oh wait this is a better wait i think
this is better like the source code for this
Wait, I should really like this.
Wait, what?
Oh, that's the wrong one.
Oh, no, I still have time.
I still have time.
That's the wrong one.
This is it.
No, I keep pressing the wrong one!
What?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
There we go.
Yes, girl.
it's really they literally said no they said minimalist i'm
giving you nothing
how am i losing this is perfect this is as minimal as you
can get i don't understand how this is a loss this is really
as minimal okay okay fine fine fine fine
There at least at least I have shoes on I
There you go this is as minimal as you can get there you go
There's no way there's no way this is literally as minimal
as you can get My fashion sense is so ahead of its time.
You guys just don't understand guys You're not trendsetter
like me.
Is this ethical girl?
It's so well What do you mean?
Laughy.
Thank you for this, Super Chat.
Thank you.
It's the true...
It's like minimalist logos.
It's literally it.
They sent Maximus and I took it personally.
I don't know.
Like, oh, the colors look terrible.
I hate the colors.
That's just my opinion, though.
You may not be ready for it, but your kids are...
You're gonna love it.
Oh, okay.
Oh, my God.
And she's showing what she's got.
Damn.
She ain't no lady.
That's for sure.
Okay, my posing will save me.
Oh, wait.
I do love.
I do like...
Wait, you can have an umbrella?
Where did she get the umbrella?
Where did...
She's serving right now.
She's serving.
What is it?
She's serving cunt.
Is that what they call it?
Is that what they call it in the fashion industry?
I'm ready to know.
That's a real phrase.
It's a real phrase.
Wadoki.
It's real.
What did...
No, you're not...
No, it's a real phrase in the fashion industry!
What did I say?
No, you don't deserve to.
Sorry, I got distracted there.
Oh,
my God.
That is the most...
Oh, my God.
That is so maximalist.
She should...
She should go to jail for this.
She should go...
She should go to jail.
Alright.
Is it my turn?
What is it?
Miss America.
Holy shit.
What a fucking name.
Miss Americana.
One star.
How is that minimal?
You're just a woman.
Like with headphones on.
How is that minimalist?
Like...
That's right.
As minimal as you can get, girl.
Oh, I fucking can't.
Now this is minimalist.
No way.
I can't.
I'm mannequin.
I'm mannequin cheek right now.
No pose Exactly if I'm gonna be minimal We don't even pose
That was on purpose Yeah But it's spying model Oh my Guys
take a photo guys Oh my god Oh my god Let's go That's Guys
take snapshots guys come on take all these i'm gonna do a
mannequin posing for you oh yeah yeah girl spread those
spread those things
okay let's go back to the let's go I'm done with you guys.
You guys are too easy.
You guys are too fucking easy.
I'm going back to my VIP lounge.
I'm going back.
I'm sorry.
You're not a challenge, children.
I need to go where I know my talents will be appreciated.
Childhood dream?
Oh, okay.
Okay, childhood dream.
She's still serving it.
Alright, childhood dream.
I know there's a balloon.
What's my childhood dream?
Guys, we gotta mix shit up.
Like, all those like reality TV.
Nothing is real.
Who entered that fashion?
What do you mean?
That's as minimal as you can fucking get.
How dare you?
My childhood dream is to be a rabbit.
I don't fucking know.
I don't know.
A clown?
Oh my god, you're right.
Wait, you're right.
Okay, I know there was a balloon here.
There was a balloon somewhere.
Oh my god, you're right, guys.
A clown.
I'm gonna steal that idea and then pick it mine, just like
fashion.
Just like fast fashion.
Exactly like fast fashion.
Okay, I need a...
Alright, let's see.
Um, it won't be that.
We're gonna pick a random makeup.
Wait, actually, can I...
Is there clown makeup?
Holy shit.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, there is!
Nice, there's clown makeup.
That's good.
We won't be a clown.
Okay, we need a...
Okay, we need white makeup.
And then...
Oh, there's the balloon.
There's a balloon.
Okay, red.
And then...
uh white there you go oh my god somebody wants to be a
mermaid mermaids aren't real
you're a stupid child
mermaids aren't real child all right let's see white there
you go all right not not your cloud somebody is in fucking
denial challenge tree all right let's see i need oh my god
they're all vip's right now wait no not this i need to go to
get my hair done i need to get my hair done breaker of tree
uh let's see any like short hair oh i could do like uh do i
want pom-poms or no i'll do this hair and then i'm basically
harley quinn i'm basically harley quinn okay oh i don't know
i don't know about the bang situation oh okay you know what
you know what i like it i think i can make it work I can
make this work.
I can make this work.
And then red, white, and then red.
Oh, yes, I can definitely make this work.
I feel like, wait, maybe if I do white and then red.
No, I'm going to do I'm going to do this.
I think this is better.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is definitely better.
Harley Quinn is a real to me Harley Quinn is literally a
therapist therapist that means that means you're saying
therapists aren't real that's she's literally a therapist
let's see oh the tootu where's the tootu where is it guys
it's tootu in the poor section or the rich section
Oh, there.
It's in the poorer section.
Alright, and then can I do, like, double patterns?
Oh, yes.
Oh, give me that gene mod texture.
Oh, yes!
Yes!
Alright, let's see.
All right.
Uh...
Me, like...
No, I don't like that, actually.
No, no, no, no, no.
Maybe this would be better.
Let me grab.
Oh, I don't know what to put on my shirt.
Guys, I need to figure out.
The corset!
There's a corset!
Oh, my God.
Where's the corset?
What the fuck's the corset?
Is this?
Yes!
Yes, girl!
Yes.
Oh my god, yes, girl.
You know how to bring it.
All right, we're gonna...
Oh my god.
You truly are.
You're her.
You're actually her.
You're actually...
Actually her.
Holy shit.
These children don't know what fashion really is until I
came along.
Oh my god.
You want to be a princess?
You mean you didn't grow up?
You want to be goddamn princess?
Oh my god.
small dreams you have okay what's this two princesses
clearly you guys have zero creativity um if you i mean um i
mean princess is a choice if you're two this is the big
leagues right now Saze the cloud What the fuck is that a
mermaid rabbit?
I wanted to be a mermaid But this is what I wanted me as a
roar mermaid To look like Holy shit Even as a doll You don't
know what colors mean
Was that another mermaid?
My god My god Trendsetter Trendsetter of the poor I want to
be Ursula but pretty Holy shit That's so fucked What is
that?
I wanted to work with frogs and other things Okay, you know
what?
That's really good That's really really good Chewie what
Basically she wanted to be a fucking frog
Does it mean I want it to be a clown?
That's right.
Ooh, that's right.
Yeah, look at the...
I hate clowns.
Don't go outside.
No, I shouldn't say that to the child.
Look,
I didn't, I didn't say it, I didn't type, I didn't press
enter, I didn't, I didn't press enter chat, let's see here.
She wants to be, she wants to be the cheerleader for the
Dallas Cowboys.
yeah i'm glad you could achieve your dream what the fuck
there's two cheers guys girls aim higher you almost said
that that's crazy i said boom boom boom boom get it get it
boom get it bomb get it get it bomb
what the cheerleaders everyone are you fucking i'm eight
princesses two girls wanted to be princesses and then we had
two mermaids this is this is rigged this is actually rigged
like this is actually a fucked like you don't deserve to be
up here i forgot what kids like i'm a fun kids like clouds
So why the fuck would people hire clowns at parties if kids
didn't like them?
Like...
Oh my god.
This is not fair.
What child wants to be a clown?
Wait, everybody left.
Everybody...
What?
Everybody left.
Wait.
Everybody wait they all left They they actually formed the
click like that's that's so fucked.
We played one game and the click was formed We played oh
shit spice girls.
I don't fucking know I don't remember what they looked bro
spice girls with children like Children don't know what The
children don't know what spice girls Girls are literally
someone's gonna dress as a little spice because that's what
they think spice girls are
Someone's gonna dress as a hot chili pepper because they
don't know what the fuck a spice girl is like
Look like she's literally a fucking chili pepper
like that's actually sorry who's thought of this theme might
be better to be honest okay we're in a regular server all
right last game guys last game i did not i did not think i'd
get this absorbed into dress to impress guys dress to
impress has been fucking wild all right What the fuck?
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
I literally just joined us to see that.
That's actually crazy.
Holy shit.
Holy fucking shit.
That's actually crazy.
That this is not what I join in.
Like, can I even make myself?
Like, I don't even...
Alright.
Oh, my God.
Holy shit.
What are the odds, though?
Like, what are the fucking odds?
For some that don't even know what that is.
Like, I'm, like, looking around.
I'm like, what the fuck?
Like...
Let's see.
Um, yeah.
Yeah, that's, yeah, that's right.
That's, that seems right.
That seems fucking right.
That seems right.
Let's see.
Wait, is there like, is there?
Is there my hairstyle in here?
Yeah.
Look as dead inside as possible.
Why does she look so...
Oh, wait, wait.
I'm not corp.
Shit, you're right.
I'm indie.
Fuck, okay.
You know what?
This is what all...
We're all dead inside anyway.
You're right.
I forgot.
Give me a second.
I gotta figure something out.
I don't fucking know.
Holy shit.
Bro, I'm just gonna give nothing.
This is what we're all like inside.
This is what we all look like inside.
I'm the manager.
You're right.
I'll just be like that.
I'll be like, I'm the manager.
Okay, let's see.
Let me at least change my shirt.
Now that I know.
Guys, I see what you're trying.
I'm an indie.
You already failed the challenge.
Okay, there we go.
I should have liked the blue earlier.
No.
Oh, not that blue.
Okay, well.
Not that blue.
Holy shit.
I can't believe I actually got this theme.
That's actually fucking crazy.
That's the last match.
That's actually insane.
Oh,
Holy fuck.
Is that supposed to be me?
I...
Five stars if it is.
My god, it's Doki Bird.
The Indy VTuber.
What's this?
It's...
Fatty, girl.
What the fuck is that?
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Batty girl Is that me?
What the fuck is this?
Nicole TV?
Who the fuck is Nicole TV?
Press some plays?
These are not V2.
These are just...
I'm the I'm the manager
yeah oh isn't that the from the fucking that new anime show
about the girl being vtuber thing isn't that Isn't that it?
That new anime show?
From the...
From... What was it about that VTuber anime show?
What was that?
Yeah, there's a new anime show about, like, VTubers.
VTuber Legend?
About how this VTuber was fucking, like, going there.
And then was, like...
And then, like, she had a hot mic situation where she was
super vulgar and wasn't...
Actually, like, the cute V-Tuber.
Legendary V-Tuber!
Yeah!
Yeah, that's it.
I heard it's really funny.
I heard that show was really, really funny.
Is that Jerma?
Is that...
What is that Jerma?
What the fuck?
Is that...
What the fuck is like some of these bits?
Wait, there's two of them?
That's not fair.
I'm fucking leaving.
How dare they're...
This is Rick.
How's there two?
Fuck this, guys.
I'm rebooting.
This should not be last game.
I can't believe there's two.
That's cheating.
Why is there two of them?
That's actually cheating.
Like...
that's at zero stars i can't it's already right before i got
in all right preppy that's actually cheating holy fuck i
can't believe it
why could they do two that's fucked that's so fucked casino
night okay this is lg This is LG for real.
Let's go gambling.
Oh my, I can't believe.
How do I...
Wait, how do I duo up with somebody?
How do I do that?
How do I duo?
I want to duo with somebody.
Oh, dang it.
Top icon?
Where is it?
This one?
Oh, shit!
Okay.
What the fuck?
Alright.
Let's... I don't know.
Who has...
Alright, Monkey Girl.
Let's duo.
Okay, wait.
Alright, let's see.
Casino Night.
Uh...
What is...
Okay.
I don't know who I invited casino night.
We're bringing it back.
We're gonna reuse the same look as before We're gonna reuse
the same look as before What do you mean?
I'm literally gambling How the fuck is that casino that
you're literally you're oh wait they're doing?
Wait, that's not fair
friends that's not how dare they how fucking dare they have
friends I'm so insulted we're gonna read you know what what
would it look like if we like oh we can't do that what's the
point all right that's not fair I can't believe they have
friends can't fucking believe it all right red bro what how
do you have six wings it's casino night not satanic night
like bro why is everybody a satan like wait what why is okay
but like why is every like literally why is everybody
fucking angels and devils.
Is this what they think gambling is?
Is this what your children think gambling is?
Like...
I think there's no way it's what children think gambling is.
It's like the fucking...
It's like the...
The game of...
The game of evil.
Gambling is the work of the of a gambling gambling is a sin
dokey how dare you what's the fuck gambling's out of the
best thing in the world or a fucking sin just like a casino
dealer i can't there's no outfit i don't have enough time oh
wait a tie i'll be like i'm the casino i'm the i'm the
casino dealer that Didn't follow the dress code.
I didn't follow the dress code.
We got a bug.
Alright, we're good.
Alright, this is how we're going to end it.
How the fuck?
Okay.
How is this gap?
How is this casino night?
I know.
I look rusty.
Jesus Christ!
I love Christ!
Jesus fucking Christ!
Your outfit is...
Like, how is this how is this casino night?
I'm calling you out.
I'm calling you fucking out.
It's a nice fit.
How is any of this casino night?
No, we changed the theme!
You can't!
What?
Just kidding.
That's so fucked.
We don't like the next theme thing you can't.
Bro!
I just got...
Bro...
I...
I wasn't there for the theme change.
This is so fucking rigged.
This is a fucking click!
Like...
This is actually so fucked.
Holy shit, I thought it was a fucking game for children.
How is there groups already?
The wrist spoiled you again.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why are our children so...
I'll just be like, gambling is a sin.
So technically, I'm a double.
I'll say that.
I'll say that at the moment.
I missed.
Bro, I wasn't invited to the fucking theme change.
Children literally forming clicks is crazy.
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I got played by goddamn children.
Oh my god.
This is not...
I don't see that
Holy shit Lost lay That's fucking right Okay, hon Bro, what
the fuck?
She honed me Bro, I I hate children So much I hate kids I
hate children Children Fucking children Oh my god She didn't
know he changed the theme I got there when When everyone was
already dressing up Bro I hate children I hate children so
much Holy shit.
I imagine getting a cape by a six-year-old.
God damn children.
And then how do I make my own server?
I need to boost my ego.
How the fuck do I make my own server?
Children are evil.
Children deserve nothing.
I need to make my own server.
Where is it?
How do I do it?
I have a hundred road bucks Oh, that was one of the LGs of
all time Oh my god Give me a sec I'm fucking making my own
server I need this I actually How do I do I do it How do I
make my server They truly are Call the server Bro she okay
hot me that's actually so fucked i can't believe i'm fucking
making my own i can't believe she okayed honey vote for
dokey okay my server's name is boost dokey's ego like
that's Alright, alright, there we go.
Okay, actually, no kids allowed.
JK.
That's my, that is my new server.
My server is called no kids allowed.
That's my server.
I've had it.
I've had it with these children in my Roblox game.
Changing the theme at the Trang That is so fucked That is
actually so fucked Like I'm so mad I'm so fucking mad
Guys My server name is No kids allowed How do I like send
you guys the link to my server How do I send you guys the
link to my server Chat No Alright invite friends Okay Okay,
I can't invite friends.
Okay, settings.
If it weren't for the stupid kids.
Okay, configure.
All right, friends.
Okay, join.
Okay, here we go.
I got it.
I got the link.
Stupid.
Now it's LG.
Now.
It's LG.
Guys, alright, we're gonna make our own theme.
If those kids can make their theme, we're gonna make our...
We're gonna do FNAF.
I say we do FNAF.
This is what I wanted.
I want FNAF, children.
I want FNAF.
No, actually, all dokees.
JK, all dokees.
Give me your best dokees.
I want your best fucking dokees.
Doki's right now.
And you can, and bonus points if you slip in some FNAF in
there too.
The Dokiverse.
Bring in the Dokiverse.
I want the Dokiverse right now.
No, I have to pay for that.
I don't have it.
I'm just going to say the Dokiverse, guys.
Ignore.
Ignore this.
We make our own theme.
I want Dokiverse.
The theme is trendy.
If they can make their theme, this is my click.
This is my Dragoon click.
That's right.
I want the Dokiverse.
I know what I'm gonna be.
I know.
I don't know what I'm going to be.
The dread dokey.
Alright, let's see.
Do not be afraid.
Let's see.
Fucking children.
I hate kids.
I'm so...
Okay, oh, we changed the theme.
Sorry, we didn't tell you.
Even though we know that you just got here.
Like, we didn't tell you that we actually changed the theme.
I hate children I'm so tilted Yes I am tilted My outfit was
so good Assault is real I had such a good outfit And then
they were like Oh sorry I'm sorry And then they okayed Honey
like that's the most part.
A fucking 13 year old.
I bet you they weren't even 13.
A fucking 10 year old fucking okay on me, bitch.
Like, they're just kids.
It's fucking real life now.
This is, this is a serious game.
Like, this is a very serious game.
This is, this is the most, serious game of my life we need
something we need like green hair at the top we need like a
green hair somewhere all right let's see okay that was crazy
that's what i was saying that was actually like I'm fine if
the child didn't okay on me then I would have been fine I
would have I can't put my ego on God and then we learn not
to tilt you I spent a hundred Roblox just to make myself
feel better I'm done oh my god this is it I'm actually it oh
my god my fit is perfect my fit is actually perfect you know
kids i actually spent a hundred bro bucks just to feel
better about myself that okay on really my broker beyond
belief i mean thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you fucking beat so many kids that i know exactly what my
fit is gonna be i hate those kids kids are fucking ruthless
they don't have they haven't learned what empathy is so they
they say what they want they're so mean i hate children
there's a croaky where is it who the fuck is that guy Wait,
there's a croaky.
Oh my god, there is.
Okay, guys, we shouldn't spoil ourselves.
Let's look outside the window.
Guys, we can't spoil ourselves, guys.
Again.
Oh, my god.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Those Overwatch players.
The go-parts, DPS players move through this game.
Because, yeah, these kids know how to deal damage.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, we can't spoil ourselves, guys.
It's gotta be a surprise.
All right, let's figure out some poses.
Let's figure out some poses that we can do.
All right, let's see.
Ooh, oh, yes!
Okay, what is this?
Is that eight?
Guys, remember eight for me.
Guys, we gotta remember it, pose eight.
Oh, this is the one sprint.
This is the one that she kept doing.
Okay, we gotta remember eight, pose eight.
Okay.
Let's see.
Ooh, yes, girl.
At 20.
We're serving some tomato juice right now.
Right here.
Oh, where am I grabbing?
Is that?
Want some of this?
You want some of that tomato juice?
No, I should say that.
Shit.
It's not fair.
Like, come on.
Oh, Madly, dude.
Okay, hand on heart.
What is that?
Oh, like that.
Oh, leg out.
Oh, girl.
I already did leg out.
Yes.
Yes, leg out.
What was the number?
Guys, guys, I forgot the number.
888.
Oh, yes.
that's fucking right easy
absolutely absolutely insane fit girl insane what what what
dokey is this which dokey is this dokey the one star you're
not gonna be in the you're not gonna be in the board of
dokeys that's for sure No, you don't call us.
We'll call you Which dokey I tried it oh summer outfit Two
stars when they have a green shirt you know what there's
green and there's a green shirt one star
Summer dokey You know what five stars that that's a girl
dokey Dokey here's our card I hope you take our offer to be
on the board of dokees oh my god that's so good why do I not
have shoes I tried making her from memory and failed I'm
literally right here like what do you mean I'm literally
streaming right now what do you mean
What do you mean?
I tried making her from memory.
Bro was not pixie turkey or something.
I don't know.
Guys, are you guys sandbagging for me to win?
Are you guys sandbagging?
Oh, I like the...
This is cute.
I like the...
Oh my god, that's so cute.
Wait, that is so cute on my phone because I have a problem.
Oh, I like that.
That's cute.
Okay, croaky.
Five star.
God, wait, what did you say that got censored?
Was croaky censored?
Like, is croaky censored?
Oh, wait, that's so good.
Rookie, my beloved, we are like this.
This game is paid to win.
RAH!
Oh, yeah, I just said cock.
Alright, voting complete.
Oh, it's the rabbits!
It's the...
What the fuck is that?
from another doki first keep believing dream as hard as you
can the lashes are on fleek sorry i gave you one star
because i wasn't paying attention that did i mean that you
were once oh wait that's current doki oh my god five stars
because it's current doki
oh my god she's serving that That's right, she's serving
that.
See.
Who's this?
Doki Man Bird.
Please give me the honor of being an official Doki First
character.
Doki Man Bird.
They don't have to be specific about the gender of birds.
Doki Bird, this is new.
Yes!
nice that's fucking right wait i can literally make a
private server and just farm guys i can wait this is
actually paid a win i can i can literally have a custom
server and then like it farms 3000 holy shit guys guys guys
all the dokees take a picture right here guys before the
timer's up all the dokees get over here We gotta take a
picture.
Not you.
Not Uzi.
You're not joking.
I'm joking.
I'm gonna be front and center.
Alright guys.
Wade, get back here, Wade.
Wade, you tapped out, Wade.
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna be here.
Alright, guys.
Do a pose.
Alright, nice.
Alright, guys.
Take a picture.
Take a picture, everybody.
That's right.
With all the dokees and Wade.
Wait, it's literally tapped out right now.
Holy shit.
All right, GTs.
GTs, guys, I'm done.
I'm done with Roblox.
Oh my god, I can't believe I spent 100 Roblox.
I'm fucking...
Let me cancel my Roblox.
Guys, I need to cancel my Roblox server.
So I...
Because it's like a monthly server.
And I need to be sure that...
Don't get charged.
Okay, guys.
Have fun.
You guys can't have...
Guys, have fun, everybody.
For an entire month, it expires on August 27th.
You guys can play Tristan Press on the No Kids Allowed
survey.
You guys get the No Kids Allowed.
There will be no children allowed in that.
server i'll i'll try if there's a child i will kick them out
all right i challenge i canceled the subscription renewal
canceled thank fucking god i'm not i'm not letting the
children and ruin this ruin this for me oh my god that's fun
though that's fun now i understand why now i understand why
this game was so popular
Thank you.
Hope this helps as much as the Robux.
Thank you for the Yakuza Superfund.
Thank you.
Doki Farms, Children for Money and Friends for Getting Kane.
Thank you for the Superchat.
Thank you.
You don't understand.
It's not even my fault.
It's not even my fault that, like, I didn't know the theme.
I was not, I joined in the server and nobody said anything.
Nobody said anything.
I was just making fun of people for having dog shit up.
Dog shit outfits.
Because I was like, oh, look at these guys.
Not having the right clothes.
I don't know.
I didn't pay attention.
I thought it was like three of them.
I didn't realize all 13.
them wasn't following the theme how is i supposed to know
oh yeah that's fun though i love fun uh i am gonna call it
here guys i i'm tired i'm gonna take a nap now but um it was
a great time playing uh dressed to impress and now i know
why this game was super popular amongst the adults and the
children um so i hope you guys had fun as well oh yeah for
those who don't know oh yeah i forgot i lost my train of
thought regarding the kso tyler one shit so like in every
generation we will always have a uh what a streamer that
likes to scream and yell at things and rage a lot but he's
also a really good way for chat to like bully as well he's
like a really good streamer to for chat to like say to bully
the streamer and like each generation has its own version of
that streamer the current one is kesa what i had was tyler
one but yes i'm gonna head off now everybody i think i read
a lot of super chat yeah like a punching bag it's called the
streamer the punching bag streamer exactly anyway guys um i
had a lot of fun today as always everybody stay hydrated
posture check get up and move around to get that blood
flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed because you
deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye